all right ready to get started sorry
about the delay
uh so today um we're gonna finish up our
discussion of mapreduce
and uh we so we began talking about
mapreduce last time
uh we worked through an example this
inverted index example that's kind of a
canonical
example of what you do with mapreduce
and today we'll talk about some more
examples
and we'll also we'll talk about the
mapreduce approach to fault tolerance
and we'll we'll talk about some
optimizations we can do on the
the basic uh approach that we talked
about last time
uh so um to recap can somebody
uh remind me from last time what are the
phases of a mapreduce job
yeah we got map shape map phase shuffle
phase and reduce space
so
let's refresh our memory on what goes on
here let's talk about the map phase
first um
so this phase is when the programmer
supplied map function
runs on all the input data can somebody
tell me
what the type of that map function is
that is
what's the type of its input and what's
the type of its output
so these are going to be the types that
the the input and the output have
conceptually
they won't necessarily be the actual
types that appear in the code that you
write
feel free to look at the paper if you
need to refresh your memory on this so
we're
we're trying to figure out what the type
of the map function is
what is its input type and what is its
output type
hmm okay so hi
i didn't think this would be a hard
question so um so the input
to the map function is going to be a
single key value pair
so the input data for the entire
mapreduce job
is going to be a potentially huge set of
key value pairs
and the map function is the code that
you want to have run on each one of them
so the input to the map function
is going to be some
some input key value pair the output
from the map function
is going to be a set of intermediate key
value pairs
right so where do these intermediate key
value pairs that are produced by
the map function stored where did they
end up after
the map function runs
right so they are going to be sent to
the reduced workers
sooner or later right but initially they
get stored locally
so they get stored in local storage on
the map workers on the machines where
the map function
was run um so let's actually look at
some examples of map functions i'll come
back to this
um so last time we talked about creating
an inverted index right
so the input to the map function
recall that so this is i'll put this at
the top this is the type of the map
function
um so for an inverted index the input
would have been a pair of let's say a
document identifier
let's say doc 1 and
a list of words in it so it would be
something like this
so this would have been one input to the
map function in the inverted index
example
and the output of the map function was
what in this case
right it's going to be something that
would
look like this so we would be have a
mapping from words
to document identifiers and so on
okay so that's what we would do if we
wanted to do the inverted index
mapreduce is more than just a
distributed fault tolerant framework for
computing
inverted indices it's a distributed
fault tolerant framework for doing lots
of things
so what if we wanted to do something
else what if we wanted to do a word
count
instead what would we want the map
function to spit out then so let's say
that this is still the input
so let's say the input is still of that
shape what would we want the map
function to produce if we were doing a
word count
sure okay so
so let's say the whole sentence is the
quick brown fox jumps over the lazy dog
so there's there's two occurs in
occurrences of the
in the sentence right so
one way to do this would be to say well
the
has to be mapped to the number two but
another thing you could do is just
emit a whole bunch of pairs that look
like this
the one
quick one
and then later the one
and so on
so why is it okay to just emit one here
because all of the occurrences of the
are going to be added together later so
it's okay to defer that adding until
after the
um after this phase it's okay to defer
the the
adding until the reduced phase however
if we felt like adding it here as an
optimization
we could so this this would be a
completely legal and valid
output of the map function but we could
also
have something that did some combination
now are we done
no right because we still have to
combine with word counts that happen
on other map workers um but we could do
this
we could combine as much as possible
locally
and we'll come back to talk about that
in a minute
okay so that's inverted index and word
count um
what about uh what about something else
what about distributed grep
um so let's say that we want to search
for a string um
let's say that we want to search for the
string dog
maybe we want all documents that have
the string dog in them
what should what should the map function
produce then again assuming that
the input is uh
is one of these pairs of document
identifier
and word list
so what would we want our our map
function to spit out if we were trying
to do this this distributed graph
so i grabbed this spelled with a p
um so so in this case
uh what we're trying to do is we're
trying we're trying to figure out
what documents have a given word in them
and
and maybe we even want the context in
which that word appears
right so instead of just saying
oh well no dog occurs in document one
we we might want this piece of text that
says lazy dog
or if we have a document
that says
i love my dog spot
then maybe the output we would want
would be um
something like this
or it could be the whole document if we
want so it depends what we want right it
depends whether we want
uh different results uh
for different occurrences of this
pattern dog or
if we want one result for every document
that has any occurrence as a pattern
right
so if dog occurs at several places in
the document
do you want that document to just appear
in the results once or do you want
uh individual occurrences of dog in the
document with their document with the
context around them
so if the input had been like i love my
dog spot who is the best dog ever
then it might the output might be
something like this so this would be the
set of intermediate key value pairs that
would be produced as the output
okay so that's a bunch of examples of
map functions
what happens after the map phase the
shuffle phase
what's the shuffle phase what happens
there
yeah so that's when the data
from every map worker the result of
running this map function this set of
intermediate key value pairs
that's when that data goes on to the
reduce worker
that will process it
so i wrote the appropriate reduced
workers here so how is it decided
which intermediate key value pairs are
going to go on to which
reduce worker
yeah so it's going to get decided by
what's called the partitioning function
which does something like
hash of the key mod r where r
is is the number of the reduced workers
so
interestingly in the paper um they don't
actually say
that the default partitioning function
is hash of key
mod r they say that there is a default
partitioning function
that's used to distribute data onto the
appropriate reduced workers
and they say that it uses hashing and
then they say for example
hash of key mod r but they don't
actually come out and say that that's
actually it
so maybe google has some secret
partitioning by hash approach that
they're not telling us about
but it's probably something a lot like
hash of key mod
r um by the way somebody just asked in
chat um
what's grep um yeah so
um grep is i let me actually look up
what grupp stands for i don't even know
so
grep is probably best known as a unix
command line utility
um for searching for it
searching for uh
lines of text that match a regular
expression
um so according to google grep stands
for global regular expression print
i did not know that until just now um so
greps uh
grips for searching for text that
matches a regular expression
in this case um we were searching like
in this example here
we were searching uh for
documents and uh places in documents
that matched this regular expression dog
and we were saying that there was some
context around the matched expression
that we wanted to keep
so depending on what you wanted to do
you could just ask for
you could ask for what are all the
documents that contain the string dog
or you could ask for what's the context
in the documents that contain the string
dogs is obviously something that
the google might be interested in
all right so um
back to this so we talked about this a
little bit last time but i
want to run over it again so at the end
of the last lecture we talked about why
why they did this instead of using
consistent hashing
because as we've discussed a number of
times now
doing hash of key mod r doesn't work
great as a way to divide up data
um if the if the number r ever changes
so r here is the number
of reduced workers that they are more
generally it would just be the number of
nodes that you want to partition data
onto
um so this isn't great if r ever changes
because it means that data needs to get
moved around
um so but why is it okay to do that in
the setting of mapreduce
we talked about this a little bit last
time but let's let's uh let's just recap
it why is it okay to do this
as the partitioning function in
mapreduce
so let's think about the context here so
the reason why we didn't want to do this
in the setting of say
dynamo is that if a node added
or what if a node if node joined the
ring or if a node left the ring
either because it failed or maybe you
took it away on purpose because you
needed those resources for another
reason
um then
the place where an existing key hashes
to is going to change
because hash of key mod 4 is different
from hash of key mod 5 let's say
which means that a whole lot of data
would move uh
and unnecessarily so right so we talked
about consistent hashing as a way to
ensure the minimum of data movement
when uh nodes left or joined
the the set of of nodes onto which
you're partitioning data
um so with mapreduce i think the reason
why this is okay
is because r doesn't change right so
this is this is an offline system not an
online system
so with consistent hashing we do it
because we always want to be responding
to client requests
right whether or not a node dies
or whether or not we're adding new nodes
it's not like we can stop
responding to client requests just
because we need to add a new node to the
system
so in that situation it's worth
taking the time to make adding or losing
nodes as non-disruptive as possible
but with mapreduce the reduced workers
are not serving client requests right
is somebody going to come along in the
middle of the mapreduce computation and
say
oh here's another piece of new input
data that you're going to handle
no there's an assumption that at the
time you begin the computation you
already have
all of the input data that you need
that's why this is batch processing like
we talked about last time
um so the mapreduce framework can make a
smart decision
about um about how many
map workers well it might ask you to
specify like how many map
workers and how many reduced workers you
need uh but it doesn't
you you the programmer okay i guess the
map reduced framework decides how many
map workers are needed
you the programmer are expected to make
an informed decision about how many
reduced workers you need
and if you chose too few and your job is
taking longer than you like
too bad better luck next time
so but the assumption is that since you
have all the input data to begin with
you're not going to be adding more map
or reduced workers to the system in the
middle of a map reduced job
in the way that you might have to add
more nodes to dynamo
to handle uh an increased
load of requests from clients or just to
store more data um
so so adding more nodes beyond the
originally planned number
is during a job is not really a thing in
mapreduce
and so that's why this this this number
uh
doesn't change we don't have to worry
about this number changing during the
job
and so this is an okay way to partition
data
so by the way
though what about crashing right what
about when mapreduce workers crash
how does the mapreduce framework handle
that does anybody remember from the
paper
yeah so somebody just wrote in chat
assign its jobs to another machine okay
but who does that who
who is responsible for knowing
what work the failed machine was doing
and then assigning its jobs to somebody
else the master
right so mapreduce involves a machine
called the master and this is actually a
very important piece that we left out of
the picture that we drew last time
so if you consider the picture that we
drew last time where we had some map
workers
on which some computation took place and
we had some reduced workers over here
and we had our shuffle
so this isn't actually all the machines
that are involved in
mapreduce uh there's also going to be a
master
up here job it is to know
who all these other machines are and
assign work out to them
and have some idea of who is alive and
who is dead
um so the master is actually uh talking
to all of these machines
so the master is responsible for
assigning out tasks to the workers
and it pings them periodically right to
see if they're still alive
if it doesn't hear back within some
given amount of time it's going to
assume that they've failed
um and the master knows what tasks are
assigned where
so if a worker fails the master will
reset the the task that that worker was
working on back to unfinished
and some other worker will have to step
in to replace it and be assigned that
task
okay so let's let's talk about this
concept of failure for a second
um so let's say that a map worker fails
so if that happens
if a map worker fails do you have to
start its tasks over from the beginning
yes you actually do
because why well because it stores its
output
remember we say it stores its output
those intermediate key value pairs
on its local disk that's that's an
important aspect of the mapreduce
framework right
that it that it just stores those things
locally which is cheaper to do than than
sending them over a network
but because it's just storing those
things locally
if it dies that disk is going to be
inaccessible if it crashes
so all of the work that it did and
stored locally has to be redone
so this is a trade-off that mapreduce
makes the design of mapreduce makes this
trade-off
they could have said that this map
worker has to store all its intermediate
data on
gfs on the distributed file system
um and then if it were stored there then
it would be accessible even if the map
worker died
right but that would take more time than
storing it locally so they considered
the pros and cons and they decided
that the right thing to do was to store
data locally
and occasionally have to pay the cost of
recomputing that data
rather than store it on the distributed
file system and not have to pay that
recomputation cost
but instead having to pay this upfront
additional cost of having having to put
everything
uh on the distributed file system
so distributed systems are full of
trade-offs like this right
and so this is an interesting uh this is
an interesting aspect of of map reduce
one of the one of the hallmarks of
mapreduce i think
uh is that um it makes the choice
of um of redoing work
quite often so
if a map worker fails all its work must
be redone
and and this isn't this is this is not
necessarily
the wrong choice right like that sounds
like a bad thing written out like that
but the alternative would have been uh
to store
its work on the distributed file system
which would be expensive to do
and maybe not necessary if if crashes
are rare
so in mapreduce they often make the
choice of redoing work like this that's
their approach of fault tolerance
approach to fault tolerance remember how
we said earlier in the course
that fault tolerance often involves
making copies of things
right we said uh replication
of of data right is one manifestation of
that so creating
replicas is one manifestation of that
resending messages so that you get
reliable delivery is another
manifestation of that making copies for
fault tolerance
and another is replication of
computation or redoing computation and
that's the choice that mapreduce often
makes
okay now reduce workers recall that they
actually do store their output
on gfs
or whatever it is that whatever
distributed file system is being used
so for reduced worker dies um
its tasks don't have to be re-executed
that
output is going to be readily available
uh
this is kind of an interesting point
though i'll come back to this later
okay so we're we've talked about
the map phase and the shuffle phase
onto the reduced phase so the data has
gotten on to the reduced workers now
the reduce function can run we talked
about the type
of the map function conceptually
can somebody tell me what the what the
type of the reduce function would be
conceptually
so the reduced workers are they're each
going to have their own partition of the
data right the data that got hashed onto
them
so every every one of these intermediate
key value pairs
that had the same key is going to end up
on the same reduce worker
right and it's the job of the reduce
function to put them together
so we could say that the reduce function
takes we could say this we could say
that it takes a set
of key value pairs
with the constraint that all the keys
are the same
uh but instead the way that they express
this in the paper is
they say that the reduce function takes
one key and a set of values that go with
it
so they say reduce takes
a a pair of a key
and a set of values
and it produces a set of output values
so let's see some examples of that um so
for the inverted index that we talked
about
um uh let me bring up that page again
which i dropped on the floor uh so
here's inverted index
um so
so what's going to be so this was the
type of the map function for inverted
index or this was an example
of inputs and outputs for the map
function for inverted index
um what would it be for um for the
reduce function
um so for the reduce function so this
was this was the
this was for the map function
for reduce
what would it look like well
an input to the reduce function
would be what
for the inverted index example
you probably have this in your notes
from last time
okay so let's talk about this uh maybe
people are a little bit confused so
so these are going to be the
intermediate key value pairs um
recall that what we're trying to
construct um
is something that will let us look up
okay what are all the documents that
that contain a given word
right um so
so the input to the reduce function um
is going to be uh uh
a key like the
so conceptually right uh it's gonna be
uh so so this is this is what it would
look like in reality right it might be
like the
occurred in document one and the
also occurred in document three uh and
so on
um and then that would get brought
together
into this list right
but we just said that um
uh that we should think of the type of
the reduced function conceptually as
already being this
right we should think of it being as a
mapping from a single key
uh to a set of values so this
conceptually speaking is already the
input of the reduced function
um and so
conceptually the reduce function really
doesn't have to do much at all
it just writes its output out to the
distributed file system basically
so in practice um you'd pass it an
iterator
and it would have to iterate through the
values and do something with them
right um but the thing it does with them
could be as simple as just writing them
out to gfs
unchanged okay so what if we were doing
word count
um what would the input to the reduce
function
look like then
so recall that reduce maps a particular
key to a set of values
or the the conceptual input type of
reduce
um is a a particular key and a set of
values so so what would it look like for
word count
right yeah it would it might be
something like the
one one one one one
uh because the maps map function emitted
um
the and one every time it saw the word
the
right um or if it had done this
optimization maybe you'd have some other
numbers in there so you might have like
the
one two one three three
etc so what does the reduce function do
with this
it just adds them all together so it
would output something like
the five and that would be a count
of every occurrence of the in every
document that is pretty a
pretty boring example i should have done
some more interesting word
um but that would be what the output of
the the reduce function would look like
for
um for word count so here
whoops it's getting quite messy here
uh but hopefully you begin to get the
idea
what about the distributed graph example
what's the input to the reduced function
then well it would be something like
document one
my dog spot best dog ever
so that would be the input to the reduce
function recall again that reduce
function maps a particular key to a set
of values
and then the reduce function would just
output its input
this is actually pretty common for the
reduced function to not do anything
interesting
so i find this kind of fascinating so we
said you know in mapreduce
um uh
we have this communication pattern right
uh this all to all communication pattern
uh where work gets mapped onto the
appropriate reduced workers
but a whole lot of magic i think happens
in that mapping onto the reduced workers
right
because since the intermediate key value
pairs that are produced by the map
workers
get partitioned on the reduced workers
by key
um that's kind of where all the magic
happens and if
if the if the job of the map like if the
if the work that you're trying to do
largely consists of uh splitting these
things up by key
then by the time you get done shuffling
them on to the correct reduced workers
uh you've already done that so it's
actually pretty common for the reduce
function itself to not have to do much
interesting all of the magic happens
in this shuffle phase where all of these
key value pairs get collated by key
questions about this
somebody asked me to look at this again
so
yeah for the for the word count example
um
so we're saying so our input is these uh
these pairs of documents in words right
on the map function the map function is
going to produce
either just this list of pairs where
it's every word that was in the input
and the number one
or if it's doing a clever optimization
it might do some
combination of of the values
so if a word occurs more than once then
then the count over here would be the
number
of times that it was that it counted
locally um
so then conceptually the input to the
reduce function so a given reduced
worker is going to deal
uh with all of um all of these
intermediate key value pairs that um
that had a particular key let's say it's
the word the or the word dog or whatever
um so conceptually the input to the
reduce function is going to be
that key and then everything that was
paired up with that key whether it's
just number ones if you didn't do the
optimization or maybe it's some other
numbers if you did
um so um so
so yeah so so there there would have
been many documents
actually and so this might have been the
result from this one
particular map worker that was dealing
with document one a different map worker
would have dealt with document two
maybe in a different one would have
dealt with document three um
but all of those uh any occurrences of
the same key the word the
or the word dog or whatever would get
sent to the same map worker
and so um that that happens
as part of the magic of the of the
shuffle phase so
um which i don't really mean to describe
as magic it's really just hashing
um but we called it a communication
pattern
but it's actually uh it important to the
computation as well
uh because it causes those um uh
those those records that had the same
key to get collated together in the same
place so that now we can easily add
these numbers up
um so somebody just asked on on twitch
who's responsible for transforming
the output of the map function to the
input of the reduce function okay
so yeah so the output of the map
function you you might ask
like uh if this is what the output of
the
of the of the map function looks like
which is these intermediate key value
pairs
but the input to the reduce function is
supposed to look like this
um who's responsible for turning this
into this so
um let me let me say again this is the
conceptual type of the input to the
reduce function
in practice um what you would get is
a key and then like some sort of
iterator that would iterate over
over these values um so
it wouldn't uh so
it's so all the data is there on the
reduced worker because it gets sent
there
by the shuffle phase um and so
um in in principle
this is the the type of the thing that
you have um
whether there's actually something uh
in like not even like whether or not
there's anything
in memory letter let alone serialized
out to disk that actually looks like
this is is another question
um there probably isn't uh but
conceptually speaking this is this is
the type of the input of the of the
reduce
so i'm glad we've been talking about
word count here because this this kind
of gives us an
in to talk about this um this particular
optimization
that's interesting so this word count
example is really screaming out for for
this optimization
right where different keys um
or where where two keys that are the
same uh
get combined right so
let's say that i'm a map worker
and i have to count occurrences of the
word dog
so we'll say that maybe the document
that i'm working it with
is like my dog
spot
is the best dog
and the fastest dog
so if i use the naive version of the
word count map function that appears in
the paper
then it would emit these
intermediate records
and then during the shuffle phase all of
those would end up getting sent to the
same reduced worker because they have
the same key
and then added together on the reduced
worker
the trouble with doing it that way is
that it wastes bandwidth
right so they could have just been added
together
on the map workers side and then the map
worker could have just been sent
or could have just sent this over to the
reduced worker
and then that would be added together
with every other map workers count for
the word dog
so the reduced worker would still have
to do addition right
but they would be adding together these
uh um these these subtotals
right from all of the map workers
instead of just adding up a bunch of
ones
so doing this on the map worker
um doing doing as much combination
of the intermediate key value pairs
locally on the map worker
is called using a combined function
and a combined function is actually just
the same as a reduce function
except that it runs on the map worker
and it's a way of doing some work in
advance
so why is this okay to do
why is it safe for us to take some of
the work that the reduced worker
normally would have done and do it early
on the map worker why
why is that legal for us to do
in the case of this word count
computation let's say
yeah so somebody just said in chat
because it has no effect on the rest of
the
the distributed result okay sure okay
why does it have no effect um so
i would say the reason why this is okay
to do
um is because addition is associative
right that is if you add a plus b
and then you add c to that then that's
going to be the same as
adding a to the result of adding b plus
c
it's the associative property of
addition
if the reduce operation that you're
doing is associative
then it's okay to do as much as you can
early in other words locally on the map
workers
and the reduced workers will still have
work to do right
they'll still have work to do but not as
much data will have to be sent during
the shuffle phase
so instead of sending um the pair
dog one a thousand times instead you can
just send dog
and 1000 to the relevant reduced worker
and the reduced worker will then add
that number 1000 together with the
totals that it got
from the other map workers for dog to
get the final result
but it's just fine to to do this
edition early uh because it doesn't make
a difference
in the in in the output
now it might not necessarily be the case
that every
um that every reduced function
uh is associative this way and so if
that's true
then then you can't do this optimization
but for something like word count you
you certainly can
questions about that
all right let's uh talk about the quiz
question from last time and then do a
quiz question
yeah so here was here was last time's
quiz uh
so we asked uh what happens during the
shuffle phase of map of a map reduce
computation so
the answer we were looking for here was
this was the place where
the intermediate key value pairs that
were produced locally on the map workers
get sent to the appropriate reduce
worker via some sort of partitioning
function
such as hash of key mod r where r is the
number of reduced workers
that's what happens during the shuffle
phase that's when data gets sent to the
appropriate reduced worker
and here's a quiz question for today
yes somebody just asked a question um
in chat which was can the reduce
function output a set instead of a
single value
uh this was just asked on twitch um so
yeah so so um
we were talking a second ago about about
the um the types of map and reduce
in the map reduce framework um so yes we
do
think of the the the output of the
reduce function as
as being a set this is if you're
familiar with uh
the notions of map and reduced from
functional programming uh
then then this might sound a little
strange right uh
so i actually want to after a minute
when we get a couple more quiz responses
um i want to talk about the difference
between
uh these types in mapreduce and
what we normally think of when we're
doing functional programming
so i'll give it like another minute or
two here
somebody else asked in in slack or in
twitch chat uh
if there were no combined function then
uh would
the would the map worker send this pair
of dog and the number one three times to
the reduced worker
yeah it would uh so that's
that's one of the things that a combined
function could do would be to do that
work earlier
all right it's a pretty good response
rate uh
let's move along
yeah so the question that was just asked
was kind of anticipating the very last
thing that i want to talk about
um so
in mapreduce these
are the the types of the map and reduce
function
at least conceptually uh so
the question that was asked was uh does
reduce reduce produce one value or a set
of output values well in mapreduce
it produces a set which might look a
little bit strange uh
if you're uh if what you're used to is
uh like the traditional uh
definition of reduced from functional
programming so let's talk about the
traditional definitions of map and
reduce uh just briefly i'm a i'm a
programming languages person so when
talking about mapreduce i would be
remiss if i didn't spend a little bit of
time talking about this
okay so so what is what's the type of a
map function
uh traditionally
so a map function is something that
takes a function
and a list and it applies that function
to everything in the list
so uh if we were
writing this down in haskell we would
say
it takes a function
uh from a to b so this is a function
and it takes a list of a's
and it produces a list of bees
and we're not uh even without writing
down the definition of map we can kind
of see what's going on here right if we
have a if we have a list of
of a's you know whatever they are
numbers whatever
um and then we have a function that
takes things of that type and turns them
into another type
then we can take everything in that list
apply the function to it and
get a list of the output type um
so in haskell it would look like this
you would write the implementation would
look like this
one possibility uh is that the list uh
here is empty
right um so if this list is empty
right the output list is also going to
be empty so in that case we don't care
what the what the function is and so you
would you typically write in haskell you
would write an underscore to show that
you don't care about that argument
so in the case where the
the input list is empty this is an empty
list
in haskell then the output list is also
empty that's that case that's the boring
case or the
or the base case um and in the other
case
um you have some function f
and then you have some list um
which has a head and a tail so it has a
first element which we'll call
x and then the rest of its element uh
which we call x's
and then what you do is you create a new
list
that just applies that function f to
x and that's the first thing in the list
and then you you stick that on to
calling map recursively
on the rest of the list again passing in
the function
so this will be a recursive call this
will go and eventually
uh you'll get to the base case uh and
then you'll be done
so for example if you were to call map
um of oh let's say
um increment
and the and the the input list was one
two three
um then the output would be two three
four
so that's an example um what about
reduce
so really briefly
reduce uh
or is it sometimes known fold r
is going to take a function that's going
to take
an a and a b and produce a b
it's going to take a value of type b
it's going to take a list of values of
type a
and it's going to take and it's going to
return a value of type b so notice that
it returns a single value not a list
um so what does this do well
if you have a list of a's and if you
have a function
that takes an a and a b and produces a b
how are you going to run that function
well you need a b
thankfully you have one right here um
so this is your b um so that b is going
to be
uh is going to be useful this is what we
call the
um sometimes you call you might call
this like the base
value
or identity
so the implementation would look like
this
[Music]
if you're reducing and this input list a
is empty
just like we saw with map if the input
list is empty
uh then it's easy right um so
if this input list is empty you can't
run this this function right because you
don't have anything of type a because
the list is empty
um you were supposed to produce a b oh
look you have a b
so you can just give back that b that
you got so
we don't care what this function is um
we have our base value or our identity
value or sometimes called our zero
value so often often traditionally
called z and the list here is empty
and then this is z so that's the base
case
here's the recursive case so reduce
takes
a function that's this function here
from a to b
uh from a to b to b um
we have our zero value z and we have our
list which is not empty
has a first element x and then the rest
of it is x's
what do we do well we're trying to
create this b
right so what we can do is we can take
our function
f we can apply it to x which is an a
and then we need another argument which
is of type b
how do we get a thing of type b with a
recursive call
so that's what the implementation of
reduce looks like none of this is
necessarily relevant to the course uh i
just felt as though
i would be remiss if i didn't talk about
this when
as a programming languages person when
i'm teaching mapreduce i should talk
about
what mapreduce means to me as a pl
person
um so so an example of this
might be well we talked about about word
count right
um so um word count was an example of
adding together a bunch of numbers so
you might do that with reduce
right so so if your reduce was like
let's see if i can put together an
example quickly here
so um so you might say reduce
um and then the function you might pass
in here might be like
add and this is like let's say like a
binary add function that takes two
numbers
um the base value that you might pass in
would be zero
and then the list of numbers that you
would pass in let's say it's like
one one two one
something like what we had in our word
count um so what's going to happen
uh reduce is going to go through and add
those things up
and then the result will be 2 3 4 5
which was the same type as this which
was what it was supposed to be
all right there's your brief
introduction to haskell for the day
um that's all i have to talk about um
i think we're through with our
discussion of mapreduce we don't have
class
on friday because friday is our
hack day uh i have office hours after
this so come talk to me if you have
questions
and monday is a holiday so i will see
you again
next wednesday take care